[موسيقى]
تعرفون الأمر المضحك الذي
أطلقه عليهم الإنترنت لي ،
وأعتقد أن اسمهم هو فيرونيكا ،
قد تعتقد أن الشعر
بين حاجبيك ليس بهذه الأهمية
ولكن لديهم شخصيتهم الكاملة
، ومن المحتمل أن يكون لديهم علاقات اجتماعية
رقم الأمان في هذه المرحلة ، هناك سبب
لكل شعرة على الجسم ، كل
شيء موجود ويقوم بعمل ما ، والحواجب بالتأكيد
لها وظيفة مهمة ، كل شخص لديه
قصة قصيرة على الأقل حول
حواجبهم وبعض الناس لديهم
قصص عميقة ومؤثرة للغاية حول
حواجبهم
[موسيقى]
اسمي صوفيا هاجيبانتيلي ،
أنا عارضة أزياء
وناشطة في مجال مكافحة التنمر في المرة الأولى التي لاحظت فيها أن
حاجبي كان عندما قررت أنني أريد
أن أبدو مثل أمي
التي اعتادت أن تقول دائمًا أن الحاجبين
يبدوان أكثر  رائع عندما يتم
تنظيفهم تمامًا وأقسم أنه في
بعض الأحيان يمكنك اللحاق بي
وحاجبي يبدوان
مستقيما في الانتباه ، فهم
يربطونني مباشرة بتراثي القبرصي اليوناني
تقريبًا في كل مرة  أستطيع أن أفكر
في أن أحد أفراد الأسرة لديه أحد أفراد الأسرة سواء
اعتنقه أو تركه أو أيًا كان
ما أحصل على قدر متفاوت من ردود
الفعل من ما هذا أو
ما الذي لم أره من قبل
شيئًا كهذا الفضول
ثم
شخص ينظر إلي
ويصاب بالصدمة تمامًا كما لو أنه رأوه للتو
مثل جسم غامض أو شيء لست أنا
لمرحلة ثانية من خلال
مئات الآلاف من التعليقات الكارهة التي
أحصل عليها ، يبدو الأمر كما لو أن حاجبي
مصنوعان من الفولاذ.  لن أغيره إلى
شيء آخر لأنك تعلم أنني لا
أحبه فحسب ، بل أعتقد أيضًا أن المزيد من
الأشخاص يحتاجون إلى رؤية هذا
حتى
أتمكن من ذلك ، لكنني لا أريد أن أكون حفلة فانيتا وأنا مؤسس
blink  لقد عملت في مجال الحاجب
لمدة 15 عامًا وكل ما نقوم به هو التصفح ،
لقد قمنا الآن بعمل 20 مليون شكل من أشكال الحواجب ،
لذا أحب أن أعتقد أنني الخبير
وأعتقد أن الناس دائمًا ما كانوا
يهتمون بحواجبهم لأنه عندما  تنظر إلى الوراء
في الوقت الذي ترى أنه كانت هناك
اتجاهات مختلفة خلال العقد
في العصور المصرية القديمة ، تم وضع الفحم
في التصفح لمنحهم العمق
واللون في أكثر من الأوقات التي جربوا
فيها التبييض وهو نوع من
تبييض الحواجب
، ثم تنظر إلى العشرينات حيث كان لدى جميع
الزعنفة حواجب نحيفة
للغاية ذات حواجب مقوسة فائقة الارتفاع.
أعطتهم الكثير من التعبير كما تعلم أنهم كانوا
يتصرفون في أفلام صامتة ، لذلك
لعبت الحواجب دورًا كبيرًا في أن
مارلين مونرو كان لها درع متصفح مدهش
اشترت الحواجب الكبيرة مرة أخرى
في الثمانينيات ثم عادت إلى
الحواجب النحيلة في التسعينيات ثم  بالطبع ،
أعادته كارا ديليفين لبضع سنوات جيدة
في حوالي عام 2012.
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
لقد قالوا إن الخيوط
بدأت في الأصل في الشرق الأقصى وانتقلت
عبر الشرق الأوسط ثم إلى
الهند ولكنها تمارس على نطاق واسع في  الهند
الآن لم يتم ممارستها حقًا في أي مكان
آخر في العالم ، لذا أود أن أقول إنها
تأتي من الهند ،
لذا فإن عملية الخيط هي
عملية بسيطة للغاية تستخدم فيها قطعة طويلة  من
القطن وتقوم بلفها حولها وتقوم
بتشغيل العقدة عبر الجزء السفلي من
الحاجب الخاص بك ويستغرق كل شعرة
من الجذور
لتتعلم أنها تستغرق وقتًا.
لفهم ما
تريده الثقافات المختلفة يتعلق
بشخصيتك وتعكس حواجبك الكثير من تلك
[الموسيقى]
بمرور الوقت وعلى مر التاريخ لدينا هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين أحببناهم بسبب
حواجبهم والسبب الذي جعل حواجبهم
محددة جدًا لأنه  تلائم هذه الحواجب
وجوههم تمامًا
، وكلما أحصل على شخص يريد أن
يحاكي حاجب شخص آخر
ويريد وضع هذا الحاجب على وجهه ،
كان علي أن أخبرهم أن مظهر حاجبك
سيكون أفضل حاجب لوجهك ،
يجب أن نقدر جميعًا  الحاجب الذي
لدينا ويجب علينا زيادة الحاجب الذي لدينا إلى الحد الأقصى
ولكن
إذا لم يكن عليك القيام
بحواجبك ولن يغير حياتك مثل
رجاءً فقط دعهم يكونون
لا يجب أن تأخذ أي شيء  الأمر خطير للغاية ،
خاصةً ليس مظهرك
لأنه يتغير كثيرًا ،
فأنا لا أجلس هنا لأخبر الناس
أنه يجب أن يكون لديك حواجبك يجب أن تنتف حواجبك ،
هذا ليس
لديك كل الحق في أن تفعل بالضبط ما
يجعلك تشعر بثقة أكبر.
أشعر بثقة أكبر مع حواجب
كما هي اليوم
تمامًا ، ربما ليس بالضبط لأنهم
ليسوا الأفضل اليوم
[موسيقى]
لدينا فكرة بسيطة إلى حد ما مفادها أن
الحواجب تدور حول إبقاء العرق
بعيدًا عن عينيك في
الواقع بالطريقة التي نتبعها  لقد تطورنا
ليكون لدينا حواجب متحركة يتعلق بكيفية
توصيل شكل وجهنا وأعيننا
للآخرين ،
هناك شيء يتحدث عنه الناس
من حيث دراسات الحواجب هو
الباركود الذي تشكل حواجبك جزءًا لا يتجزأ
من هذا الرمز الشريطي وهذا ما يفعله الناس
يقرؤون وجهك ، يستمعون إلى ما
تقوله ، ثم ينظرون إلى حاجبيك
ولكنهم لا يتصرفون
بوعي بطريقة لاشعورية ،
إنها إيماءات صغيرة جدًا
ولكنها ذات مغزى كبير  ful
[موسيقى]
نرى أنه على سبيل المثال ، هناك بعض
الأبحاث التي تُظهر أن الأشخاص الذين
خضعوا لحقن البوتوكس على جبينهم
أقل قدرة على إظهار التعاطف
لأنهم لا يحركون حواجبهم ،
كل تلك الطرق التي نعبر بها عن
أنفسنا من خلال حواجبنا  هذا
جيد تمامًا وهو ممتع تمامًا
ولكن إذا بدأنا في الحد من قدرتنا على
إظهار المشاعر ، فسيبدأ ذلك في
إعاقة اتصالنا بأشخاص آخرين
[موسيقى]
لذا فقد فقدت حاجبي
منذ حوالي ست سنوات عندما بدأت
أعاني من تساقط الشعر
جيدًا  في المرة الأولى التي فقدت فيها شعري ، كان عمري
11 عامًا. لقد أصابني ذلك بشدة في ذلك الوقت ،
وكنت
خائفًا من مغادرة المنزل عندما تعرضت
للتنمر في المدرسة ،
لكنني سأقول إنه من المحتمل أن يكون
لدي الآن أكثر مما
كنت أفعله
عندما  كنت أصغر سنًا وهو أمر
مخيف حقًا وكل ذلك كان
من البالغين
[موسيقى]
بشكل أساسي كنت قبيحًا بليب بيب
بيب أم لا عجب أنني كنت
أعزبًا يشبه الطريقة التي أفعل بها
ذلك قبل أن أعتقد أنه كان هناك جو
شيء كان على وجهي كان علي أن أتعامل معه
فقط لجعلهم يبدون جيدًا
الآن ،
لقد أدركت تمامًا ما يفعلونه
وبدونها ، فأنت فقط بلا تعابير ،
لست قلقًا بشأن نمو شعري
مرة أخرى ولكن إذا كان بإمكاني فقط
لديّ حاجبي ورموشي لأنني
ألاحظ حقًا الاختلاف الذي
أعلم أنني اعتدت أن أكون محبطًا جدًا لنفسي
لأنني لم أكن مناسبًا لما يسمى
بالمثالية المثالية للجمال ، وذلك عندما كان لدي
شعر ، يحتاج إدراك الجمال إلى التغيير
الذي نحتاجه  أن تدرك أن كل هذه الأشياء
في الخارج هي مجرد
ملحقات لمن نحن
بصراحة الجهل هو نعمة إذا كنت لا
تفكر في متصفحك على الإطلاق ،
لا أريد أن أزعج سلامتك
[الموسيقى
]  الإفراط في تجربة الحواجب ، افعل
ذلك بشعرك ولكن
حواجبك مقدسة للعناية بها
فهي جزء لا يتجزأ من من تشعر أنك
في العالم ومن تشعر أنك تريد
إظهاره من حيث الهوية من حيث الجنس
الجنسي  فئة التوجه الجنس
والمكان في w  orld هم مهمون جدًا
[موسيقى]